rtl matin six minutes pour trancher
bonjour jean marc jancovici bonjour vous
êtes associé fondateur de carbone ou
quatre cabinets de conseil spécialisés
sur la transition énergétique et
l'adaptation aux changements climatiques
dont j'en fais du verdier bonjour je
rappelle bien entendu la météo sur
france 2 actuellement dirigeants de
force 8 conseil est une société de
conseil dans l'environnement
merci à tous les deux d'être avec nous
en direct sur rtl des ouragans qui se
succèdent dont l'un était atteint une
puissance historique hier soir le
président macron dans son discours en
grèce a nommé un responsable
le réchauffement climatique on écoute le
président cette émotion n'est sincère et
conséquente que si ceux qui les éprouve
veulent bien avoir l'esprit de
conséquences et vouloir s'attacher aux
causes profondes qui crée ce type
d'événement et c'est pourquoi la france
restera déterminé à lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique est tout faire
pour prévenir ce type de désastres
l'esprit de conséquence jean marc
jancovici vous êtes d'accord avec le
chef de l'état
irma est la conséquence d'un dérèglement
climatique si les conducteurs se met à
boire il y aura statistiquement plus
d'accidents maintenant dire que un
conducteur qui a bu c'est parce qu'il a
bu qui a eu un accident et que s'il
avait pas but il aurait pas eu c'est
toujours impossible à dire voilà on est
exactement dans le même genre de
situation c'est à dire que savoir s'il y
aurait eu un ouragan s'il n'y avait pas
eu de réchauffement climatique personne
n'en sait rien par contre ce qui est
absolument certain c'est que le
réchauffement climatique favorise
l'augmentation de l'intensité des
ouragans
ça c'est un fait qui est documentée
depuis maintenant dix ou quinze ans en
particulier parce qu'il ya 40 ans de
recul sur l'atlantique nord où on voit
l'intensité des ouragans augmenter
progressivement sur les 40 dernières
années
philippe verdier comment réagissez vous
aux propos du président de la république
c'est une parole avant tout diplomatique
politique scientifique il était un petit
peu rapide par rapport à la science la
science qui dit qu'elle a besoin de
temps pour démontrer le lien de cause à
effet entre irma ce cyclone là et ici le
rôle du réchauffement climatique dans
cette histoire vous me dites quoi là il
fait de la pop hits enfin il fait de la
politique
je pense que comme l'ouragan se dirige
en plus vers les états unis la parole et
quand même un destinataire en
particulier c'est donald trump olala la
vraie question qu'on se pose tous et le
réchauffement climatique aujourd'hui est
il à l'origine ou donne-t-il une ampleur
puisque c'est finalement ce que nous
suggérait jean marc jancovici
particulière à ces événements qui nous
impressionnent énormément quelle est
votre réponse avoue philippe et les
scientifiques que j'interrogeais ou ce
que ce qu'on peut lire à travers la
presse mehr international américain
australien et même français ne peuvent
pas démontré aujourd'hui le lien de
cause à effet entre irma et le
réchauffement climatique
il ya des indices l'océan plus chaud
bien sûr qu'ils favorisent cet ouragan
extrême qui est vraiment hors normes
maintenant des ouragans de catégorie 5
qui aura lui un hacker notamment en 2005
et ce qui est aussi étonnant c'est que
pendant dix ans il y en a eu quasiment
pas eues et alors vous en concluez quoi
qu'on n'aurait pas été agréable quand
j'entends bien ceux liés à ces réalités
c'est ça on a quand même 40 ans de recul
quarante ans de recul c'est très très
peu à l'échelle du climat donc ça veut
dire qu'ils font encore beaucoup de
temps pour déterminer de manière très
fiable
le lien de cause à effet même si à des
indices jean marc jancovici ce qui est
sûr c'est que le réchauffement
climatique favorise l'apparition
d'ouragan de plus en plus intense favori
il ya deux raisons à ça c'est que ça
augmente la température de la couche de
surface dans l'océan ce qui est un des
moteurs des ouragans et ça augmente par
ailleurs la différence de température
entre la température près du sol et la
température de la stratosphère à plus de
10 km d'altitude la différence de
température augmente
et ça ça joue aussi le rôle de pompes
aspirantes quand il ya des phénomènes
extrêmes qui se crée donc il ya deux
moteurs en quelque sorte les deux
carburants qui nourrissent exactement en
autre de là vous êtes en train de mettre
un peu plus de carburant et un peu plus
de comburant dans le moteur et vous vous
posez la question si de temps en temps
le moteur va pousser plus fort la
réponse est oui
maintenant est ce que cette fois ci très
précisément je le redis si on avait
écrit l'histoire sans réchauffement
climatique on n'aurait pas eu cours à
gand c'est une réponse c'est une
question à laquelle personne ne peut
répondre il faudrait que la terre ait
plusieurs histoires ce qui n'arrivera
jamais qu'est ce qui vous frappe dans
tous les discours qu'ils sont tenus et
notamment sur le plan politique
concernant le réchauffement climatique
et ses conséquences philippe verdier
c'est le sait la temporalité le temps
politique est très très court à
l'échelle d'un
demanda le temps dont ont besoin les
climatologues est beaucoup plus long et
c'est vrai que c'est très agaçant parce
qu'on aimerait savoir si oui ou non y
remet à est dû au réchauffement
climatique
maintenant c'est vrai que les
climatologues il notamment ceux du giec
et établissent un rapport tous les sept
ans ça veut dire que qu'un président
comme donald trump n'aura pas de
rapports du giec sur son bureau pendant
tout son mandat
en revanche nous sommes d'accord jean
marc jancovici nous ne sommes pas
victimes d'une impression quand il
compte quand on observe je dirais la
fréquence et l'amplitude des phénomènes
dont nous parlons alors la fréquence
pour le moment il n'y a pas de tendance
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas constaté
d'augmentation
statistiquement significative de la
fréquence sur les ouragans sur des
séries longues
par contre il ya un résultat très très
clairs sur les ora gants de catégorie 4
et 5 dont la part relative a doublé en
l'espace de quarante ans c'est à dire
qu'ils sont deux fois dans l'ensemble
des ouragans
oui il y en a deux fois plus aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont de catégorie 4 et 5 par
rapport à ce qui se passait ya 40 ans
sur l'atlantique nord risquaient une
possibilité de retour en arrière
aucune la durée de vie du co2 dans
l'atmosphère du surplus de co2 qu'on a
déjà vu dans l'atmosphère c'est des
milliers d'années donc il n'y a aucune
réversibilité en ce qui concerne le
changement climatique est par ailleurs
changements climatiques m au changement
donc ça veut dire qu'on va voir des
choses qui n'existaient pas avant
donc c'est normal qu'on voit apparaître
sans être toujours capable de
l'anticiper trait à l'avance des choses
encore une fois qui n'existait pas avant
excusez-moi j'ai ainsi parce que c'est
pas très motivant vous nous dites que
quoi que nous fassions que nous fassions
quelles que soient nos efforts nous
n'aurons pas de retour en arrière
quoi que vous fassiez quelles que soient
vos efforts vous n'aurez plus jamais 20
ans je sais pas si ça vous empêche
d'être heureux et en tout cas c'est une
réalité est là c'est exactement pareil
et pour revenir sur le politique moi ce
qui me frappe aussi c'est sa temporalité
se dire qu'on s'occupe du problème quand
il ya un ouragan
puis dès que l'on ralentit le problème a
disparu et demain on va se désole du
fait que les ventes de voitures
fléchissent un peu après demain se
désole du fait que la production d'acier
fléchissent un peu etc
mais à chaque fois qu'on augmente ça on
augmente le co2 donc à un moment faut
qu'on se mette d'accord avec nous mêmes
philippe verdier
le là où je suis pas forcément d'accord
avec jeanne d'arc 6 sur la fréquence de
ses cyclones
ils sont quand même en nombre ils sont
quand même dans la toundra bassin
atlantique beaucoup moins nombreux en
tuant 12 ans ces dernières années en
2005 et c'était une année exceptionnelle
il a vu une trentaine de deux phénomènes
depuis 2005 on a assisté à une baisse du
nom de ses cyclones dans la zone
caraïbes et états unis savaient pas dire
que demain il y en aura pas beaucoup
plus ne manque de visibilité on navigue
à vue
vous convenez que ça quand même un temps
court une dizaine d'années avait bien
sûr c'est un temps court d'autant plus
que le recul des deux est de 40 ans
seulement donc ça veut dire qu'on a peu
d'informations historiques et qu'on
navigue à vue
impossible de prévoir si l'année
prochaine sera une année où il ya
beaucoup de cyclones ou pas qu'est ce
qu'on a à tirer de ce qui vient de se
passer qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'on
comprenne de la situation que nous
connaissons qui émeut tout le monde qui
inquiète parfois et où on voit par
ailleurs des gens qui sont dans une
grande difficulté une grande souffrance
des français à l'autre bout du monde
je leur dis quelque part il faut qu'on
se mette d'accord avec nous mêmes c'est
à dire que à 7 milliards et demi dans
une petite boîte qui s'appelle la
planète terre et dont les la taille
n'augmente pas il faut qu'on arrive à
trancher aujourd'hui on est en pleine
incohérence je le redis c'est à dire que
lundi on dit tiens on veut augmenter la
taille de l'économie c'est à dire
augmenter les flux physiques et en
particulier augmenter les émissions et
les rejets de toute nature et puis mardi
on se dit ah c'est quand même ennuyeux
il ya des conséquences dans cette
affaire et on et ont préféré ne pas les
voir
je le redis il faut qu'on se mette
d'accord avec nous même en semaine à
venir décroissance ça veut dire plus d
excuse moi mais des simples au bout d'un
moment c'est à dire décroissance pour
respirer alors j'utilise des termes
simples pour quelque chose qui
évidemment beaucoup plus compliquées
alors après l'abandon de vos 20 ans j'ai
une deuxième bonne nouvelle pour vous la
décroissance elle a commencé en europe
depuis dix ans si vous regardez tous les
flux physiques en europe sur les dix
dernières années la production
industrielle les mètres carrés
construits les tonnes transportées en
camion etc
ça fait dix ans qu'il est en train de
baisser et soit dit en passant mon
pronostic c'est que ça va continuer pour
des raisons énergétiques
parce que l'europe aujourd'hui et en
approvisionnement énergétique contraint
à la baisse on n'y peut pas grand chose
c'est géologique et donc ça va ça va
baisser
les derniers mots de philippe les leçons
à tirer c'est qu'est ce qu'on va faire
quelques os qu'on va le construire ces
petites îles saint barthélemy et saint
martin qui sont des vrais paradis
est ce qu'on va voir un peu de
résilience et de sagesse pour ne pas
construire trop près du littoral pour
construire autrement pour pour se parer
à d'autres éventualités
merci beaucoup en tout cas l'un et
l'autre de nous avoir aidés à essayer de
tirer des enseignements de cette
situation que nous continuons d'analyser
de commenter aujourd'hui sur l'antenne
d'rtl merci jean marc jancovici
merci de philippe verdier bonne journée
à tous les deux 10 calvi sur rtl
expliqué pour mieux débattre
dans un an